i think that is very human to be curious
and so much of what i've tried to do is
driven by curiosity
the questions that i ask are questions
that every child asks
however i think we do a pretty good job
of essentially eliminating
that curiosity from most people since
i'm particularly
enthralled by and amused
with the everyday world it's relatively
easy to find questions by just looking
outside the window taking a walk
i have far more questions than i can
potentially answer
some of the questions that i've studied
in the past include figuring out how
the brain folds understanding how flags
flutter
understanding the mathematics of origami
understanding how animals move
and trying to basically see how
mathematics allows
for a way to move from one problem to
another
looking for general principles there's a
different approach
that one can take to mathematics which
is to think of it as a
very very powerful language perhaps the
most powerful language that we know
that allows you to try and describe the
world try to predict the world
you can use it as a writer does and
write prose
you can use it potentially as a poet
does
a poet often breaks rules an important
aspect of
this is not to worry too much about
where it will lead
so i don't really have a broad agenda
one thing that i have learned to become
comfortable with
is to recognize failure and be
comfortable with failing at most
questions that i start out to try and
address
but because there is no dearth of
questions associated with understanding
the behavior of matter on the everyday
scale either in the physical world or in
the biological world it's not really a
problem because there are so many
questions